So in these first two steps of the
alcohol metabolism pathway, we've essentially learned that this,
intermediate acetaldehyde, is what causes the alcohol flush
reaction. The ethanol itself mainly causes the intoxication.
And it turns out the acetic acid is
just largely a harmless metabolite. So knowing that
an accumulation of acetaldehyde can actually cause alcohol
flush, which scenario would result in the most
severe alcohol flush reaction? Take a look
at each answer individually. Notice how it's
different. They each change the ADH or
the ALDH2 enzymes. Look carefully each option, and
notice that they change with regards to
the activity level of the enzymes. Reduced
activity, or an enhanced activity. Go ahead
and pick which answer you think is best?